these statutes are not just stone and
metal they're not just innocent
remembrances of a benign history these
monuments celebrate a fictional
sanitized Confederacy ignoring the death
ignoring the enslavement ignoring the
terror that it actually stood for that
speech by New Orleans Mayor that's
mission Landrieu about removing
Confederate statues in his City made
headlines nationwide this year this
morning we take a closer look at that
debate and other national issues playing
out on the local level in our continuing
series we call it American Voices mayor
Landrieu was here at the table
he's also by the way president of the US
Conference of Mayors and he joins us
live and in color always good to see you
ma'am or to thank you for having me that
speech has received four hundred and
fifty thousand views and I watched you
last night at Mayor Bloomberg's business
dinner and so many people came up to you
saying they were moved or they were
touched by your speech and I'm there's
one thing that stood out for me in it
you said you all did not elect me to do
the easy things you elected me to do the
right thing why was this the right thing
to do you spoke with such passion about
it well you know as as the nation tries
to lurch towards healing it's really
important that people feel open and
inclusive the city of New Orleans has
always prided itself on being a diverse
place a place where all people are
welcome a place where all kinds of
people can come and enjoy themselves
those monuments have been up there as a
testament to in my opinion was a false
narrative of history you have a city
that's 60 67 percent african-american
individuals have to walk by those
statutes which are in public places of
reverence and it was just really not who
I thought the city of New Orleans was or
who we have a war is I thought it was
important of course correct history you
said were a city in a country of two
truths and we can't ignore both truth
well I think I think that is absolutely
true and one of the things that we've
been doing since Katrina is rebuilding
the city of New Orleans not the way that
she was but the way she always would
have been if we would have gotten it
right the first time and of course this
nation has had a really difficult time
struggling with the history of the Civil
War those monuments we'll put up
purposefully and intensely to send a
message that for some reason the
Confederacy was not going to become part
of the United States of America and it
was important to state really really
clearly that that's not who we were as a
people what's interesting is that some
people have said why does it all stop
taking down monuments Jon Meacham raised
that point in a piece that he wrote in
which he said the question and the
answer is was the person to whom a
monument is erected on public property
devoted to the American experiment in
Liberty and self-government Washington
and Jefferson and Andrew Jackson were
each owned slaves but each was committed
to the transparent idea yeah I think
he's correct about that there's a clear
delineation between revering certain
people and others these individuals put
these monuments up because to honor them
for trying to destroy the nation not to
support the nation to really deny the
issues of liberty and justice for
everybody not to support it and so
that's not who we ever were in the city
of New Orleans and so they didn't
reflect our values and so I thought it
was really important that we take them
down do you believe that those places
should be replaced by monuments to other
ideas and other people I think I think
the people in communities ought to use
their public's places in ways that lift
people up and not tear them down and I
think each community has to construct
either either monuments or other pieces
of art or green spaces that reflect who
they are as a people and that celebrate
who we are in an affirming way not at
not a destructive way those particular
monuments were put up by the Daughters
of the Confederacy pursuant to something
called the cult of the Lost Cause which
of course really honored us not being a
nation and and that's why it was really
important just to reflect what our true
history wasn't by the way they were put
up way after the Civil War that's what
kind of a historical lie right one of
the reasons that speech went so viral is
because you clearly put a lot of thought
into the words of the language that you
use I'm curious when you hear our
president speak and some of the colorful
language he chooses like yesterday even
at the United Nations calling kim
jungeun the rocket man what is your
reaction to some of the language this
president has used and and is it helpful
do you think I think I think it's
wrongheaded and I don't think it's
helpful at all this speech that I gave
was an invitation for people to look
into their souls and to really kind of
discern where we had been and where
we're gone and to come together as a
people to transform to a better place
that's what that was about it wasn't an
antagonistic speech designed to pummel
people or
beat them into submission that that
doesn't really work that speech
yesterday was actually sad and and and I
think that most Americans are going to
think that historically well like we
said the number of people who have been
tuning in and listening to your speech
continues to grow your words of wisdom
thank you so much for thank you very
much good to see you